yep in the week that is the trailer
pocalypse we got another trailer we got
a new trailer for Jurassic world I do
like the trailer what I really like
about the trailer it's almost like they
address the problems that fans had with
the other Jurassic world trailers in
this trailer a lot of fans myself
included in the last trailer we were
like how is Chris Pratt controlling
velociraptors that doesn't make sense in
this trailer Chris Pratt's like it's not
about control it's about a relationship
and before I was like dinosaurs are
awesome enough why do you feel you need
to genetically modify dinosaurs to make
them cooler and in this trailer Bryce
Dallas Howard like corporate felt that
making a new dinosaur would up the wow
factor Chris Pratt's like they're
dinosaurs that's Wow enough and it was
like all right I would say it's like
they're listening if this movie was made
after fans are already bitching about it
but this was already filmed which
tells me that we should all just I guess
have more faith granted this movie's the
exception not the rule for every movie
that gets it right there are like 28
others that it up so we get shots
at the big genetically-modified huge
holy a source eating people or the
indominus rex i believe it's called or
the i rex and the velociraptors are
brought out which is funny because the
whole thing is like Chris Pratt's
controlling the velociraptors or at
least giving them that relationship
where they trust him but you see shots
in here where velociraptors are out
killing people so obviously that
gets away from them it doesn't work out
and I like that about this trailer it's
almost like they're running with the
theme of you cannot control life life
finds a way which I'm glad about know my
gripes before work the fact that they
were in the movie I just want to know
that the movie addresses the fact that
these things are absurd you guys notice
they have dr. woo back the guy from the
first Jurassic Park movie the dude looks
no older securities case of dr. Liu but
ultimately I'm looking forward to this
Jurassic world movie I'm open to them
doing more I'm glad they're
addressing the fact that certain
perspectives and things in this movie
may or may not work out having a
relationship with the Raptors
genetically modifying dinosaurs and
Malcolm would be turning in his grave
right now if he's dead I don't know if
he's dead he might be alive he might be
alive and come in in the post-credits
scene for one big fat I told you so at
the end of this movie all in all looks
entertaining this looks to be an
entertaining summer for sure it's gonna
be a great summer I don't know I think
there are gonna be a couple of great
movies in there but this doesn't look to
have some really cool intensities like
when that helicopter falls through the
pterodactyl dumb I was like oh you guys
are screwed now and all the pterodactyls
get out and start picking people up and
carry them offals like that's what
happens I will always love the original
Jurassic Park movie most of all but if
this movie
like next-level kind of take on the
original Jurassic Park concept was
certainly more action that's just
obvious from the trailer I'm still down
for it but I want to know what you guys
think about it so the Jurassic world
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more